hey if you haven't already got it get
yourself a copy of answer the Internet
the card game it's available right now
in the link in the bio or you can get a
bar salal Mart Amazon or Spencer Gifts
play along with us I'm Jimmy O yang you
can catch my new stand-up special on
Amazon Prime video it's called good deal
and I am here to answer two Internet's
questions what is the weirdest thing you
could find on your buddy's laptop what
is or like what have I actually found I
don't know you guys I think we around
the same age back in the day I think you
should [ __ ] with people so when they go
to the bathroom you changed their
desktop you know screen saver - what was
it called like lemon party or somethin
party was but y'all should know if you
don't Google and I'm still sure I'm sure
I'm still there yeah glue at work in
fact yeah Google it on your zoom are you
sharing the same lemon party alright
next question you see your significant
others mother naked do you bring it up
or never speak of it again as a single
man I will have to pay someplace and
pretend here you just gotta ignore it
why would you bring it up we're like
what's a conversation like it's like oh
I guess that's a mom guess I'm still
pretty firm up there like what what's
the point of ever bringing it up I guess
I guess you can be think like let's just
get this out in the open get it over
with it won't be I'm on your side
but trying to play devil's advocate
maybe just get it out in the table or
you know what it to get ahead of it in
case your mother-in-law tells your wife
right hey Jimmy saw me naked today I was
weird so I want to get ahead of it yes
yeah yeah yeah hmm now I still wouldn't
say nothing I'll just play those odds
if you could have all the powers of
Harry Potter but you could only have sex
with inanimate objects would you do it
I mean that that's that's me up until
the age of 20 I think without the powers
of powers of Harry Potter yeah why not
do I don't know can I can I do it like
what I'm like say 60 after my sexual
prime I'll do it you know I I don't want
to do it now you think your sexual
problems gonna go till 60 okay okay
maybe sexual prime is a big range but
like until like I have the ability to
have decent sex yeah like 30 more years
of [ __ ] did you Jimmy Jesus Christ
a lot of [ __ ] left in me man okay
last question would you rather all of
humanity be able to breathe underwater
and fly or all of humanity be able to
communicate with extraterrestrial life
um this is an interesting one if you
were just to ask me personally I think
it'll be great to be go underwater and
fly because who knows we might never be
able to find et yeah extraterrestrial
life but for all of mankind I think
there's a big question man if were able
to breathe on the water and fly some
crazy [ __ ] might be happening you know
we'll probably destroy the ecosystem
even more and you probably got idiots
flying like when they're being told to
stay at home that might be a problem too
so I think you we're we're [ __ ]
destroying the earth and we only use 30%
of it you give us 100% this thing's got
a decade left saying so so like in the
individual level I would love to have
the power to fly go underwater but at
the same time I don't want everyone to
have that power I feel like it would
just be a [ __ ] show
so communicate with extraterrestrial
life I guess because that's probably not
even gonna happen in our lifetime you
need to talk to some amoebas and like
water bears government just said we got
UFOs around
Jimmy you're making strides of course
yeah yeah hopefully hopefully space for
us that's the moment when we jump the
shark is when we talk into aliens out
there